I've noticed that almost all the really
good machine learning practitioners tend
to have a very sophisticated
understanding of buyers invariant but in
various one of those concepts as easy to
learn but difficult to master even if
you think you've seen the basic content
advisor variants is often more nuanced
to attend you'd expect in the deep
learning error another trend is that
there's an less discussion of what's
called the bias-variance tradeoff you
might have heard of this thing called
the bias-variance tradeoff but in a deep
learning arrow that less of a trade-off
so it's still tougher biases with
overall variance but just talk less
about the bias-variance tradeoff let's
see what this means
let's see you know data set that looks
like this if you fit a straight line to
the data maybe a logistic regression fit
to that this is not a very good fit to
the data and so there's a cluster of
high bias or we say that this is under
fitting the data on the opposite end if
you fit an incredibly complex classifier
and maybe a big neural network or you
network with a while the fit engineers
maybe you can fit the data perfectly but
that doesn't look like a great big key
there so there's a cost v of high
variance and this is on overfitting the
data and there might be some classifier
in the teen with a medium level of
complexity that you know maybe exceeds
the curve like that that looks like a
much more reasonable fit to the data and
so that's a call that you know just
right right somewhere in between
so in a 2d example like this with just
two features x1 and x2 you can plot the
data and visualize bias and variance in
high dimensional problems you can't plot
the data and visualize the decision
boundary instead there are a couple
different metrics that we'll look at to
try to understand bias and variance so
continuing our example of cat picture
complication where that's a positive
example and there's a negative example
the two key numbers to look at to
understand bias and variance will be the
training set error and the death set or
the developments etc so for the sake of
argument let's say that you're
recognizing cats and pictures is
something that people can do nearly
perfectly right and so let's say your
training set error is on one percent and
your death set error is for the sake of
argument let's say is 11 percent so in
this example you're doing very well on
the training set but you're doing
relatively poorly on the development set
so this looks like you might have over
fit the training set there's some how
you're not generalizing well to this
hold on cross validation services
development set and so if you have an
example like this we would say this has
high variance so by looking at the
training set error and the development
set error here you would be able to
render a diagnosis of your algorithm
having high variance now let's say that
you measure your training setting of
deadside error and you get a different
result let's say that your training set
error is 15 percent I'm writing your
training so ever the top row and your
death set error is 16 percent in this
case assuming that humans achieve you
know roughly zero percent error that
humans can look at these pictures and
just tell this cat or not then it looks
like the algorithm is not even doing
very well on the training set so if it's
not even fitting the training data as
seen by well then this is under sitting
the data and so this algorithm has high
bias
but in contrast is actually generalizing
at a reasonable level to detect entrance
performance or death sided only want to
send word since the forms in the
training set so dude album has a problem
of high bias because was not even
training
it's not even fitting the training set
well the dissimilar to the left most
plots we had on the previous line now
here's another example let's say that
you have 15 percent rating set error so
that's pretty high bias but when you
evaluates on a death set it does even
worse maybe it does know 30 percent in
this case I would diagnose this
algorithm as having high bias because
it's not doing that well on the training
set and high variance so this is you
know really the worst of both worlds oh
and one last example if you have you
know 0.5 training set error and 1% deaf
set error then maybe your users are
quite happy that you have a can cause
fire but only want to send ever then
this will have a low bias and low
variance one subtlety that I'll just
briefly mention that we'll leave to a
later video to discuss in detail is that
this analysis is predicated on the
assumption that human level performance
gets nearly zero percent error or more
generally get the optimal error
sometimes called Bayes error for that
sort of Bayesian optimal error is nearly
zero percent I don't want to go into
detail on this in this particular video
but it turns out that is the optimal
error or the Bayes error were much
higher say there were fifteen percent
then you look at this classifier fifteen
percent is actually perfectly reasonable
for training set and you wouldn't say
that's high bias and won't set pretty
low variance so the case of how to
analyze bias and variance when no
classifier can do very well for example
if you have really blurry images so that
you know even a human or just no system
could possibly do very well then maybe
Bayes error is much higher and then
details to how this analysis of change
but leaving aside this subtlety for now
the takeaway is that by looking at your
training set error you can get a sense
of how well you are fitting at least the
training data and so that tells you if
you have a bias problem and then looking
at how much higher your ever goes when
you go from the training set to the DEF
set that should give you a sense of how
bad is the variance problems are you
doing a good job generalizing from the
training set to the death set that gives
you a sense of your areas all this is
under the assumption that the Bayes
error is quite small and that your train
and your death sets are drawn from the
same distribution if those assumptions
are violated that the most sophisticated
analysis you could do which we'll talk
about in the later video now on the
previous slide you saw what high bias
high variance look like and again she
had a sense of what it could cost dialog
by what does high bias and high variance
look like it's kind of the worst of both
worlds so you remember we said that a
classifier like this the linear
classifier has high bias because under
fits the data so this would be a
qualifier that is mostly linear and
therefore under fit the data we're
drawing this in purple but if somehow
your classifier does some weird things
then is actually overfitting parts of
the data as well so the classifier that
I drew in purple has both high bias and
high variance where there's high bias
because by being a mostly linear
classifier is just not fitting you know
this quadratic right shade that well but
by having too much flexibility in the
middle it somehow gets this example in
this example over since those two
examples as well so this cost that kind
of has high bias because it was mostly
linear between either maybe a curve
function a quadratic function and it has
high variance because had too much
flexibility to fit here those two
mislabel all those alive examples in the
middle as well in case this seems
contrived well it is this example is a
little bit contrived in two dimensions
but we're getting high dimensional input
you actually do get things with high
buyers in some regions in high barians
in some regions and so it is also to get
consoles like this high dimensional
inputs that seem less contrived
so to summarize you've seen how by
looking at your algorithms ever on the
training set and your algorithms error
on the dev set you can try to diagnose
whether has problems high barriers or
high variance or maybe both or maybe
neither and depending on whether your
algorithm suffers from bias or variance
it turns out that they're different
things you could try so in the next
video I want to present you a what I
call a basic recipe for machine learning
that lets you most automatically try to
improve your algorithm depending on
whether as high buyers or hide there's
issues so let's go on to the next video